sherry it's time to go deeper into the
woods and find fall at the bellagio
rocky she is live at their botanical
gardens exploring the new autumn display
hey rocky
hey jc yeah this is one of my favorite
places in vegas because it's ever
evolving it's beautiful and i have today
i have to say that this season it smells
good so i'm here with leslie she's the
manager of the conservatory you bring
all of this together of course with your
designer at libby who we will talk to
you later in the show so tell us what
went into this to this display
many many hours of blood sweat and tears
but we have our pumpkin patches around
that are grown for us in half moon bay
california so this pumpkin behind you is
795 pounds
we leave them in the field until the
very last day because when they start to
get mature they put on 10 pounds a day
wow okay things you wouldn't know unless
you speak to the manager herself
and last season it was into the woods
and this one is deeper into the woods so
a little similarity there but what makes
it different
it's different in that you feel a little
bit deeper you can see more critters we
have a lot of woodland critters we have
squirrels and hedgehogs prairie dogs
ladybugs grizzly bears we have some
snails that are darling fountains over
here so a lot of things to see our fox
family
over our koi fish pond so a lot of
things for the animal lovers beautiful
and what i like to tell people is this
is not just for tourists it's for it's
for locals alike so tell us why
it's never the same room twice whether
it's the same christmas show year over
year the same fall show year over year
we always try and have some hidden
moments this year we incorporated a
custom designed set of fairy wings that
you can take a photo op in front of over
by giordini and we just always try to
mix it up and bring something new and
interesting four families here in vegas
visiting or living here and what we were
talking about was the difference between
night and day so can you tell us really
quick about the night time
night time features are intelligent
dynamic lighting so
and at night it's a whole different
experience it's very zen it's got a
little cell tree
and it kind of goes with the whole
vibe of the hotel right now we have our
fall decor throughout so the fall
experience starts at the front drive
with pumpkins and leaves and then behind
the front desk we have two additional
foxes which are a little wink to what is
actually in the conservatory itself i
love it okay coming up later in the show
we're going to talk to ed who designed
this place so grab your pumpkin spice
lattes and come on down i'll send it
back to you sounds great thank you rocky
we'll check back in with you later on in
the hour with our pumpkin spice lattes
and sushi